salut ça va être la première vidéo sur
internet où on va citer plus de dix
marques alors qu'il ya pas de classement
de produits alors là il ya deux
solutions ou c'est super intéressant où
je suis le roi des imbéciles je vous
laisse faire votre opinion là-dessus
mais je vais pas ouvrir de sondage pour
ça j'aurai un peu trop peur de la
réponse
[Musique]
l'année dernière j'ai écrit quelque
chose pour mon spectacle dont je me suis
pas servi et je suis retombé sur ses
nattes récemment je me suis serait
dommage de pas s'en servir donc je vous
fais une vidéo là dessus sur le sens
caché des logos des marques
on les voit tous les jours on les a tout
le temps sous notre nez et pourtant on
sait pas toujours ce qu'il ya de cacher
intérieur ou pourquoi ils ont été faits
comme ça et puis quand un moment donné
tu comprends tu fais hommes et oui mais
c'est évident pourtant la première fois
que j'ai cette révélation c'est quand je
me suis rendu compte du slogan la paire
y en a pas de la paire y en a pas de là
c'est sûr vous me trouvez débile mais
moi j'ai mis des années à me rendre
compte que la paire c'était une paire et
qu'il y en a pas deux je sais pas si je
dois continuer cette vidéo après cette
révélation je sais que certains d'entre
vous l'année dernière ont eu aussi cette
toute petite révélation quand ils sont
aperçus que la menthe à l'eau qui avait
dans le générique une menthe à l'eau ça
fait mantallot m
ent à hello donc aujourd'hui je vous
parle de 10 marques audi logos de
marques ea dont certains jeux dont vous
connaissez peut-être le sens mais tout
ça m'étonnerait le premier dont je vous
parle c'est fedex fedex en fait un
service de livraison vous savez un petit
peu comme ubs ce genre de choses et
comme tout service de livraison on part
d'un point pour aller un autre point ce
que vous n'avez peut-être la vie dans le
logo c'est qu'ils ont caché une flèche à
l'intérieur du logo qui symbolise donc
le transport et le côté on y va c'est
rapide et bien juste là vous devriez le
voir maintenant c'est entre le e et le
xx de fedex dans le texte expédition on
à la flèche le deuxième vous l'avez
peut-être déjà vu ça par contre c'est le
logo de toblerone où ça et s'il ya une
montagne en fait déjà c'est pas
n'importe quelle montagne à l'intérieur
de la montagne à un ours si vous ne
l'avez pas vu maintenant vous voyez
lourd c'est sur cette tour cela
spécifiquement c'est le symbole d'une
ville de la ville de berne et berne
on retrouve les lettres dans toblerone
dans le bon ordre on retrouve berne dans
toblerone donc déjà berne est caché dans
toblerone est lourd ce qui est caché
dans la montagne qui est le symbole de
la ville de berne est un hommage qui a
voulu faire la créatrice du toblerone
puisqu'elle est originaire de cette
ville le troisième qui connaît bien si
on vient d'île de france et le logo de
la ratp le logo de la ratp on voit tout
le temps c'est un cercle avec un visage
à l'intérieur mais est-ce que c'est pas
plus que ça ça fait partie des logos
vraiment que j'aime bien et que j'ai pu
découvrir par moi même bien qu'un jour
j'étais dans le métro je fais bien sûr
mais c'est ça tout simplement le cercle
représente la ville de paris et le
visent
avec ce court comme ça bleu représente
la scène c'est ni plus ni moins qu'un
schéma très schématiser évidemment de la
ville de paris de la scène qui le
traverse pour le quatrième on s'attaque
à un classique c'est à dire que là parmi
vous il y en a plein qui vont faire mais
moi je connais tellement ça qu'ils vont
vouloir aller dans les commentaires pour
hurler qui connaissaient déjà et y en a
qui vont le découvrir pour la première
fois et souvenez vous si vous le
connaissez la première fois contre le
fait voir tu fais tu as well c'est le
logo carrefour le logo car forget sait
pas ce que vous voyez mais en réalité il
représente simplement un c majuscule
c'est étant la première est de carrefour
évidemment et ceux qui ne le connaissent
pas sont en train de le chercher en
serbe et non je vois du bleu et du rouge
en fait il est dessiné dans le vide et
comme il ya une disproportion des deux
couleurs utilisées on ne le voit pas
apparaître mais si on faisait le contour
on verrait le sait de carrefour à
paraître ça c'est le vrai le beau et
c'est son vrai sens en 5e vous ai mis
deux pour le prix d'un en fait il ya un
logo qui avait fait débat il ya quelques
années quand il est sorti le nouveau
logo du tgv quand il était sorti à
l'époque on s'était aperçu quelque chose
d'amusant moi je l'avais découvert avec
philippe vandel sur canal+ à l'époque il
avait une chronique c'est que si on
retourne le logo du tgv du train à
grande vitesse ça fait un escargot ce
qui est dommage pour un train de cette
vitesse quand même mais là apparemment
soit c'est une grosse farce de
graphistes et personne ne l'a vu soit
c'est juste quelque chose qui n'avait
pas du tout été anticipée donc s'il n'a
rien à voir avec le nouveau newman par
exemple qui lui est un an bigras
volontaires se dire que newman si on le
met là et qu'on le retourne on relit
encore une fois newman ça c'est le genre
de truc que j'adore les zambiens 1/6 un
petit peu plus léger je ne sais pas si
ça aussi vous l'aviez remarqué ou pas
mais dans les galeries lafayette se
cache une tour eiffel et la tour eiffel
c'est les 2 t de la fayette forcément
les galeries lafayette représente la
france donc paris donc la tour eiffel à
cet hymne aussi qu'on n'avait pas
expliqué quand je l' ai découvert c'est
juste un jour ça m'a sauté aux yeux
là où je suis très étonné c'est jamais
l'avoir vu avant vous pouvez me dire
dans les commentaires si c'était votre
cas ou pas c'est le cycliste du tour de
france si on regarde le logo du tour de
france en fait il un cycliste qui est
caché mais simplement à l'intérieur ça
se voit pourtant et pourtant on le voit
pas et je pense que maintenant vous êtes
en train de le voir évidemment ce
cycliste je sais pas comment j'avais
fait pour le rater pour le huitième on
reste toujours sur une marque c'est sur
une marque que vous connaissez bien
c'est amazon ce qui me fait d'ailleurs
penser à vous dire merci puisque depuis
le 18 mai je suis dans le top 3 des
ventes tous livres confondus grâce à
vous et j'ai même été un
moment premier nous vous disons merci
alors soit amazon évidemment on voit une
espèce de sourire c'est comme s'il y
avait deux yeux et un sourire un petit
peu mais il ya un message caché pas
tellement gâcher d'ailleurs c'est que
c'est une flèche qui fait rejoindre à et
z est le message que voulait faire
passer amazon à l'époque c'est que sur
amazon on trouve tout de a à z surtout
qu'à l'époque c'est un peu plus
librairie d'où le fait de mettre le
wales on ne vienne c'est pas une marque
c'est un locaux dont vous avez
l'habitude de vous faire voir le logo
sur le carnet que m'avait fait une
abonnée à melun fabriqué de a à z un
seul juste hyper bien fait donc c'est le
bouton power on off
là vous constatez de choses déjà vous
constatez que ce symbole vous est
familier quotidien et vous constatez
aussi à quel point j'ai écrit mal
puisque même ça je suis pas foutu de le
faire correctement j'avais fait une
vidéo vous faisait les dessins que vous
m'aviez demandé je sais plus voilée
c'est une vidéo de 2016 mais on avait pu
voir à quel point c'était horrible
pourquoi des gens à jour ont décidé que
ce serait le symbole on off et bien pour
deux raisons déjà ça représente un
circuit qu'on peut ouvrir et fermer si
on bascule ça donc comme un circuit
électrique mais il ya un deuxième centre
c'est que ce cercle représente un os et
ce très représente 1 1
en clair on est sur du binaire 0 ou 1 ça
marche ou ça marche pas mon dixième
symbole c'est un symbole qui est un peu
passionnant c'est celui du bluetooth
alors déjà est ce que vous savez
pourquoi ça s'appelle le bluetooth et
pourquoi c'est ce symbole là un petit
peu bizarre
l'ensemble de tout ça c'est un hommage à
un roi danois le roi harald blatant et
en anglais on disait pas aral de blattes
ans on disait aral de bluetooth parce
que vous savez on donnait souvent des
petits qualificatif au roi et bluetooth
ça veut dire les dents bleus en français
on aurait dit attention voici harald v
d'emblée et le peuple de son pays et des
autres pays il appelait les dents bleu
parce qu'il a apparemment il raffolait
de myrtilles la manche à longueur de
temps et ça pleut idées dans ma part
bouffer des myrtilles il a fait des
trucs de biens aral il a réunifié toutes
les tribus danoise pour en faire un
royaume
donc il a unifié pour que tout
fonctionne ensemble et là vous voyez un
petit peu je veux en venir le système
bluetooth est fait pour que tout
fonctionne ensemble en communiquant
facilement et les initiales de sarralbe
lattes en bois râle de pout tous chp et
la rue mme danoise pour le hc ça l'art
une danoise pour le b c'est ça et si on
réunit filets 2 le hcb mélange et ça
nous donne ça parce qu'on s'en ferait
pas un petit 11e en bonus parce que là
clairement pour terminer le mot je
voulais faire une vidéo légère où il
n'ya pas à réfléchir un truc on fait à
oui d'accord à ça je sais pas donc on
peut se permettre d'en faire un 11e on
va juste parler du logo de toyota à la
base le
toyota c'est censé représenter aussi des
coeurs qui ont les uns dans les autres
et puis une tête d'animal on peut voir
une forme avec une corne mais c'est
encore plus malin que ça dans le logo
même de toyota on a toutes les lettres
de toyota on a t au
y ôter à est celui qui a réuni toutes
les idées à l'intérieur de ce simple
logo basse et sur quelques traits je
trouve que c'est du génie
et puis pour terminer je vous informe
qu'il va y avoir des séances de
dédicaces pour le livre le 24 juin à la
rochelle le 28 juin quand ça rentre au
compte-gouttes c'est en train de
s'organiser au compte-gouttes donc à
chaque fois je mets ça sur sur la page
du site internet également dans la
description de la vidéo qui parle du
livre et vous retrouvez d'ailleurs le
lien de cette vidéo dans la description
vous tiendrez également très rapidement
au courant du prochain live qui aura sur
la chaîne et en attendant je vous dis à
très bientôt
merci de vous abonner penser surtout à
liker la vidéo à très bientôt de charles